[Applause]
all right welcome back safety blitz
starting two times super bowl champ
roddy harrison jack collinsworth start
with the afc side of things the bangles
in kansas city we just saw this matchup
not too long ago and the bengals had to
play as aggressively as they basically
have all year to go get the win couldn't
really stop mahomes so start me from the
bengals defensive side what do they have
to do in the rematch
well first we all we we sit back and we
always talk about the bengals offense i
mean right we we love the bingo's
offense but really this bengals defenses
they played extremely well trey
hendrickson he's been outstanding um
wilson the linebacker devon bell he's
been fantastic jesse bates i love their
secondary the two corners eli apple was
balling he's competitive i you took him
from two or three different places and
brought him to cincinnati now he's
playing like he's a legitimate
cornerback about to play in the afc
championship game i just think that zach
taylor he's done such a great job of
letting them guys just show their
personality you talk about a player's
coach but just allowing those guys to be
who they are and joe burrow man let me
just tell you man like we talk about
well he's better than what tom was at
this point in time it's it's not even
close i mean the type of leadership that
he's shown you know him speaking to his
team and saying look guys we're not the
underdogs anymore we belong here we
belong in the super bowl we're going to
go get it that's the type of leadership
that doesn't come from a 20-something
year old that does not happen in
national football league so when i talk
about the bingo's having someone special
at the quarterback position joe burrow
is that and i played with the worst
quarterback of all time and ryan lee and
i played with the greatest quarterback
of all time and that's tom brady and
this kid at this point in time he's he's
a lot better than brady
yeah cheat obey woozie has had a great
year playing corner as well they've
really done a nice job of grabbing these
guys right who are sort of at the middle
of their careers and then bringing them
in here signing them to a little
contract extension giving them a little
money not crazy money but they're
they're having a great second half or
really middle of their career right here
in cincinnati it's not something the
bengals have ever really done very well
so that's that's how this defense has
been brought together if you go back and
look at the first time these two met
week 16 it was kansas city was scoring
almost at will it was seven nothing it
was 14 nothing and then the way the
bengals won was that they just continued
to match the points it was 14-7 now it's
21-7 now it's 21-14 borough was just
matching him and eventually he drug him
deep into the waters of the fourth
quarter and then he was able to go
overtake him so that's the question
right can joe burrow go do that at
arrowhead where it's going to be loud as
all hell he's not going to be able to
hear anything can he do it without the
communication go be able to score points
with kansas city when mahomes is playing
a home game and no sound to worry about
so all of a sudden joe burrow is going
to just choke up he's going to go to
kansas city where it's a loud stadium
and all of a sudden oh my god the stage
is too big i don't believe that you have
i'm not signing that at all it's harder
no no i'm not tart i'm not being
sarcastic to you i'm just i'm just being
sarcastic
you know but no you have joe burl
right you have joe burrow and of course
they have the silent count they have
other things that they go through man
this team is just so focused they're not
afraid of kansas city when you beat a
team the first time you want you really
um bent on beating them a second time
because you feel like you can beat them
a second time and it's not anything
special you have to do one of the things
i could say defensively from them they
just have to do a better job of tackling
on both sides both defenses have to do a
better job of tackling there's a lot of
big plays in that game you know they're
going to take shots you know they're
going to take shots the most important
thing when you play against teams that
have all this level of talent you got to
be able to um tackle and joe burl he has
to understand that he's going against a
veteran defensive coordinator that one
is one multiple super bowls being highly
aggressive
with his defense and defense coordinator
steve spagnola i saw him against brady
all the different blitzes everything
that he dialed up and trust me he
doesn't have to blitz he he's a he's a
coach that has four guys that can get to
the quarterback joe burrow was gonna see
every blitz under the sun so he better
be prepared and i know he will be ready
yeah and and i i fully believe in joe
burrow i mean i've been on this train
all year that i believe and these guys
are so young and they've been winning
all these games we borrowed won the
national championship basically played
one of the best college offense if not
the best college offense ever with jamar
chase so these dudes are so young they
just don't know any better they they
just feel like they can beat anybody's
ass they're like bring them in here
we'll beat them and they can't they they
just might be right they just went into
tennessee and they just beat the titans
so they might just go be able to go beat
whoever the heck they want but now you
got to go in there and he had this line
earlier in the year which i thought was
kind of funny that you know nfl stadiums
aren't really that loud right that was
his line he's like the sec you go play
in one of these big time sec games it's
true that's a loud stadium you know the
nfl is not that loud will it be
different though arrowhead when you're
in the afc championship game like how
different is that level when you get to
this deep in the playoffs
oh
that's all they say you know how loud it
is man and those fans are absolutely
crazy it's cold it's loud and they get
to scorn on you and patrick and i'm
gonna tell you man that's been the
biggest difference that i've seen in
patrick mahomes if you watch patrick
mahomes he is finally healthy last year
obviously in the super bowl he wasn't
healthy he's finally healthy he's
running around he's making plays with
his legs and that's really been the
biggest difference his legs have really
saved kansas city um this postseason
jamar chase you ripped off three
touchdowns and a couple zillion yards
that first matchup as well tyron
matthews the last thing i want to hit on
tyra matthew if he's hurt man how much
does he mean to that secondary because
he's got to ugly against the bills late
i mean he's huge man because he's the
leader in that secondary he's the guy
that he's very versatile player he's a
smaller guy so he plays safety he can
come down he can play what we call the
dime or the money position lining up
over tight end he's also versatile
enough to play over the slot so when you
get him you get a guy that plays
multiple positions a guy that gives
those young guys confidence and i told
you last time we were there i really
like their cornerback position because
those guys are underrated and you watch
them play they're feisty man like you
know they'll dance i remember i was at
ward knocked the ball down against um
jamar chase and then jamar chase came
back and caught a touchdown he started
celebrating but that's the type of
competitiveness i like you playing
against one of the best receivers on the
planet eventually he's going to beat you
but i love the fact that they compete on
every single down they're not afraid to
play man-to-man coverage either
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports